oh shoot
[Music]
hey what's going on everybody from first
week Feast I'm Sean Evans and you're
watching hot ones it's the show with hot
questions and even hotter wings and
today we're joined by Steph Curry he's
the greatest shooter in NBA history of
four-time NBA champion with a pair of
MVPs and nine All-Star Game appearances
to his name but it all had to start
somewhere and you can see his journey
from Overlook Prospect to NBA legend in
the new documentary underrated which is
now available on Apple TV plus Steph
Curry welcome to the show thank you for
having me Sean I appreciate it man how
are you around spicy food before we get
started uh so growing up I didn't want
anything to do with spicy food and then
uh when me and Aisha got married and
she's got the Jamaican Heritage and a
lot of that Cuisine has to do with some
spice so I learned pretty quickly so now
I'm pretty comfortable with it but I
don't want to talk myself up knowing
what's wrong what's going on here
[Music]
foreign
I'm ready to get started what we got
okay all right
[Music]
there we go I saw
that's pretty good man finger looking oh
wow
so underrated which is phenomenal by the
way details your Genesis is a three-star
recruit dismissed by the Juggernaut
colleges called too small and according
to 109 NBA draft Scouting Report will
never be a star in the league because of
a lack of explosiveness how do you think
things would have been different if you
would have ended up at Virginia Tech or
Duke like do you think you'd be where
you are right now it's a great question
because
I I don't think so because it's you know
the brand of basketball that I play now
was predicated on a system that Dave was
in college Bob McKayla mastered and the
only reason I I think I'm as successful
at is because I got to learn with reps
so having gone to Tech or Duke or
whatever maybe I like ride the bench my
freshman year and I'll get that
experience I don't know if I'd be the
same player so it's kind of a message to
go go where the best you know fit is for
you as much as you might want to have
the the pedigree or the resume to say I
played in the ACC I played in a power
conference that's all cool but
um you know myself you know Damian
Lillard John Morant guys who went to Mid
major colleges they'll find you wherever
you're at and so that's kind of the I
didn't
I had Faith at the time I didn't know
how I would plan out but
um yeah I wouldn't change that
experience for anything so I'd rather
play than just sit on the bench and say
I gotta I got a you know power
conference school on my chest
I already like it it's probably gonna be
my favorite one
you know what time is
going good mm-hmm
hmm
a little Thai green curry hot sauce does
the name proud oh absolutely I like the
flavor though there we go it's really
solid
I'm really I'm not I'm getting too ahead
of myself it's all right you can be
proud of yourself all right the flavor
too yeah the spice is one thing but the
flavor is pretty solid
so I want to congratulate you on an
amazing weekend of golf one of the
American Century Championship an eagle
on 18 a hole in one earlier in the
weekend what is hitting a hole in one
leg for you like is it like hitting a
shot from 75 feet on the quarter is it a
uniquely singular sport experience
uniquely singular experience just
because when I shoot a 75-footer or
whatever a heave I probably made that
shot before if it's in practice or maybe
in a game before and honestly I expect
to make it versus a hole in one even if
you hit a shot and it's right online
like the odds of it going in or slim to
none so when it goes in that's when I
lost my mind I started sprinting 150
yards down the whole I celebrate I
basically blacked out and if I act like
that when I make a 75 footer unless it's
to win the NBA Finals then you'll
celebrate but it's kind of like ah I was
I've meant to do that versus a hole in
one it's different different
[Music]
zesty lemon pepper I like lemon pepper
I'm trying to shoot you freaking too
fast as hell when you're the when you're
the host of myself then you have to
think about trying to keep up with your
race no no no because I tried to get it
down first because I got a question you
know what I mean I try to I try to walk
you know I try to load I feel you I feel
you it's a timing game over here too you
know
you master this crap for sure
for sure
so NBA Jam popularized the concept of
being on fire all right but there was an
influential study in a 1985 edition of
cognitive psychology that said that hot
hand Theory or Street shooting is a myth
as the NBA's all-time leading
three-point shooter what's your take on
that whole thing like does being on fire
feel real to you oh absolutely
there are times
and catch the ball
and you've maybe made one or two in a
row
and this is in practice or a game
whatever the case is but mostly in the
game like everything else does not exist
the only thing that exists is as long as
I can get this shot off and it's not
going to get blocked
the rim feels like the ocean and it's
one of the most rewarding feelings for
us and you know myself and other great
Shooters like that's all you work for is
the muscle memory and the mechanics that
develops that confidence so that when
you're in a game like you're not
surprised you're in those moments but
when it happens it's like yeah this is
what I've been waiting for it's like a
psychological or physical phenomenon
that you can feel like this study they
don't know what they're talking they
don't know what they're talking about at
all unless you've been in that 94 feet
and you know like you've seen Klay
Thompson scored whatever 37 and a
quarter or you know 60 and three
quarters you know when I had 60 in one
game that's literally a the tangible
physical sensation of all I need to do
is just get this ball off my fingertips
and it's going to go in
um because you also know the opposite of
that when you can hit the broadside of a
barn and everything feels good but the
results aren't there so you that balance
of like where you are on that spectrum
is like the ultimate game within the
game
[Music]
I don't like anything that has Jay Fuego
in the title oops his hot sauces get
hotter the labels turn into like warmth
there were no liabilities on it right
there
all right now we're talking
in your opinion what is the NBA team
staff role that's most important to
keeping the machine moving but doesn't
get enough of the credit
we have a guy named Rick celibrini and
shout out to Rick who is
in this crazy I know Rick and we've
formed a great relationship and I don't
even know what his title actually is
he's like the go-to on injury management
injury prevention like all of those
things that you know allow our bodies
and our minds to be sharp for Peak
Performance we've had a couple run-ins
at times because I want to be a lot more
aggressive on
like when I get a tour of Labor in my
shoulder or ankle and sprains and all
that like I'm thinking about the
shortest timeline
impossible for me to get back on the
court he's more realistic he's more
realistic and more player friendly in
terms of being on the conservative side
of like let's take all the variables
into play Let's make sure we're talking
about longevity and not just the Here
and Now
that's why you see guys playing you know
a lot longer I know there's a slowed
management conversation and a lot of
that falls from the narrative
perspective on the players like they
don't want to play 82 games that's not
it it's you know you know there's smart
professional well-studied individuals
that understand how to you know prepare
athletes to play not just now but for
you know years and years and years and
years and performing a very high level
and that's why I'm you know going into
my 15th year I feel as fresh as I've
ever been
um so shout out to Rick shout out to
Rick
Los Calientes Rojo
my lips are burning I'll let you know
that that's what's going to happen you
know keep me updated keep me updated
here we go yeah I don't know if like
acknowledging the heat is a good or bad
thing right you want to block it out or
you want to just I'm here I think you
basking it you know that's what I think
you do okay yeah my lips are on fire
yeah speaking of a uniquely singular
experiences you know like hot ones just
like that you know while you're here you
might as well soak it in absolutely
so you're a self-described popcorn
addict and in 2019 the New York Times
published your power rankings of NBA
popcorn throughout the NBA throughout
the entire league and you rate it all on
a proprietary one to five scoring system
of freshness saltiness crunchiness
butter and presentation how would you
articulate the difference between your
top rated popcorn the kind that they
serve at Dallas Mavericks games yes and
then the lowest rated popcorn that they
serve at Clippers and Lakers games
basically you got presentation like I
wanted to you know it should lock on
your eyes the uh the butter the salt
ratio it's very important very important
like I'm a traditional the bells and
whistles just make it you know good nice
and buttery salty
uh the the crispiness right it can't be
like too mushy you know you know it has
to have like a nice little crispiness to
a little definitely texture in the mouth
so I that was my ranking system I went
through every Arena gave them like a one
through five
on each of those added them up and it
was kind of exactly what I expected in
terms of you know the Arenas that I know
where I look forward to playing in those
Arenas not just because of the
environment because of the popcorn's on
point absolutely but I I I'm not lying
when that came out the next year
everybody dialed the game up there was
uh it was impressive so I went every NBA
player to thank me for you know the
popcorn that's going around the league
right now you deserve it absolutely
absolutely all right are you ready to
move on second half here all right
picking things off this is I'm a third
quarter player so this is the you gotta
get through this just gotta get through
this all right where are we at the spicy
Sharky spicy shark
kind of sweet up front and then it's
coming in I was confused I thought I
grabbed the wrong Wing at first but no
no no
I did not
yeah
I'm right there with you I'm right there
with you keep going yeah
I just got I'm starting to sweat now
nothing's gonna happen it's gonna be
like you're at the free throw line in
the third quarter here as we go on you
know who
all right
your unique insight as a child of a 90s
Pro I am curious when you and your dad
talk about like his MBA versus your MBA
what are the things that you guys end up
talking about
I mean the physicality is always the one
thing that everybody talks about like
all the hard fellas they had back and
they was just real on the leagues you
know adapted uh appropriately but just
the overall spacing right like when you
watch games back in the day in the 90s
at all times it looked like there was at
least nine people inside the three-point
line usually just five to six people in
the paint and just the different you
know X's and O's and and floor splicing
and play calls that they did
um he told the story today about a
game-winning shot that he had in Madison
Square Garden
the way he just described the play is
like somebody double teamed the post and
kicked it out to him on the strong side
corner I'm like that hasn't happened in
like 12 years in the NBA I don't
remember the last time we had a double
team to a strong side kick out for a
butt naked open you know game-winning
three in Madison Square Garden so it
wasn't just the game-winning shot it's
just like how it happened and he said
it's so casually like oh yeah that was a
good defensive for you it's like that's
not everybody's Fanning out to the 3.9
they rather you to try to shoot a shot
in the paint and you know for a game
winner instead so game has changed
drastically obviously I feel like I've
had a lot to do with that but you know
those are probably the main call outs he
he likes to talk about and
the contracts
[Music]
jalapeno Chico here I swear when you
said the name
all right I'm trying to do what you just
said trying to acknowledge yeah right
now
I'm basking it
it's okay it's gonna be all right
I'm not the only one come on
mm-hmm
I'm competitive so I really I really
want and you know not to lead the
witness but we've never had an NBA
player tap out no no I'm not it won't be
it won't be today however you got to
wheel me out of here come on
so I've heard you credit Klay Thompson
shooting form is being more pure from a
textbook standpoint than yours can you
explain what you mean by that because
from sitting on the couch like they both
look pretty good to me how would I
explain it I'd say his is more
repeatable for the average person but I
mean by that it's
it's more kind of uniform from the
ground up
so for all the hoop heads you know like
you get
you're uh you get your uh
you get your balance uh from your feet
and then your power from you know the
base and you work your way up from there
like you can't really get
your consistency and repeatability by
trying to throw it and sling with your
hands and your arms and your wrist so he
has like the most stacked kind of form
like everything's in line all of his his
angles are right
[Music]
and um like if I was gonna take somebody
who's never shot a ball before and put a
ball in your hand I would put you in
Klay Thompson's positions
because like everybody shoots
differently like all the greatest shoes
in the league we all have different
releases of different forms but Clays is
the one that if you just took a snapshot
it's just right here it's just extreme
it's pretty I call it the prettiest jump
shot I've ever seen and then if you are
giving advice on how to shoot what
movements in idiosyncrasies in someone's
mechanics which ones are adaptable with
enough practice and then which ones are
fatal if done wrong
the getting really technical the angle
of your elbow because it's really hard
to if you're able if you have like that
you call it the chicken wing
or the
the I don't know what you rarely see
this one but there have been some that
kind of come up through here and then
bring it back out but this is the one
you see the most the chicken wing is
deadly just because
it's hard to create the same Arc with it
and the same power you can get
everything from here but as soon as you
get here you lose it as long as you're
in your elbows kind of as close to 90
degrees as possible I'm much more
confident in somebody being able to
repeat that because that's the one I
hate to see it's like the deadliest sin
in basketball shooting uh the chicken
wing the chicken chicken wings on topic
yes this next chicken wing speaking of
lethal chicken wings so this is the one
that like
like the popcorn thing like presentation
he came and look at your eye goes right
here first
[Music]
talk to me all right here we go the bomb
Beyond insanity
yeah immediately
all right I didn't even get that thing
in my like on my teeth and it hit me
man I'm just real sweating now yeah
like for real sweating all right and
then just be careful around the eyes I
went backhand on you that's smart
all right
do you remember the first time
good show this is the show that is oh
shoot wait why is it just sitting on my
tongue like right on the front it keeps
growing it keeps growing at you like the
worst is never over
all right you do you remember the first
time that you ever pulled up from 40
feet in a game like how old were you and
do you remember what your coach's
reaction was oh my God
that is insane I know I I almost said
you willingly do this every day
you get paid for it I know yeah yeah you
know and you're passionate about your
job yeah um
oh my God I did it in high school
uh I know I missed and thankfully my dad
was on the sideline so my head he was an
assistant coach my head coach couldn't
really like overstep and like chastise
me in another game but I definitely got
an earful when I got in the car on the
way home
you trying to get through this freaking
sauce
it doesn't get any better no it only
gets worse it only gets worse I know I
know I know you know during my middle
school era all right kids in games would
try that like Allen Iverson spin
crossover a lot usually it's a
disastrous results do you remember like
the player that you would emulate when
you were that age like so many kids now
it's like you for them like who was your
model
the motto is Steve Nash and Reggie
Miller
you see this tier yeah it's very
dramatic yeah I get real emotional about
talking about when these two legends
that were such great influences on my
game
Reggie because he was a master of
creating space without the ball find a
way to get separation to go out and get
a court uh get a pass and quick release
I never could emulate his form because
he'd do like this when you shoot it was
you never you never teach that but the
movement of the ball so I try to blend
those two guys together
um but then the funniest me and my
brother there's a guy Alonzo Mourning he
had like this really methodical free
throw routine that me and my brother
would really emulate and we did it you
know when we were playing Au he'd have
his wristband he'd do like a methodical
like and wipe it off the sweat like he'd
get locked in then he do another little
bounce another little balance he'd do it
again and they shoot the freedom Suite
we always I don't know why we just love
that iconic free throw routine because
it was very big man of him like we were
little guards and it was like kind of
out of pocket for us but
yeah I was just
a roundabout way of saying Steve Nash
and Reggie Miller were my my guys with a
little splash of Alonso warning a little
splash of the big feeling how are we
doing fantastic
freaking fantastic
let's do it I need a sweater yeah you
need the morning routine
deep breaths
oh my goodness man fourth quarter fourth
quarter
I just want to know I'm winning a real
real significant bet in my family right
now oh you are
they didn't think you'd make it through
they had no faith in me underrated
almost there underrated
come on I told you I'm competitive come
on bring it how much did it mean to you
that Kobe picked up on your baby face
assassin nickname you know it seems like
he saw the Killer Instinct in you before
a lot of others
that is one of my favorite memories and
like compliments I've ever gotten in my
life because it was like two or three
different um
kind of interactions there one I didn't
even know about till
way after the fact
it's my rookie year and we were playing
the Lakers at home and he's on the bench
I think we're getting beat at the time
but I come down to court and I do like
this little pump fake situation hit a uh
a leaner off the glass
and as I run on the court the camera
knocks in on him for some reason and he
like points to or links to the guy
sitting next to him on his teammates
and uh kind of Mal's like yo he's nice
but like that's the that's the dopest
thing in the world Kobe is validating
your game and he's just saying you play
like for real for the first time that's
just freaking amazing then the second
time we were playing in a preseason game
he's doing that Mama mentality thing
where he's picking me up full court in a
preseason game in the first quarter I'm
like you turn around and he's like this
like standing there and like doing
defensive slides like staying in front
of me like yo what is happening right
now this is freaking Kobe Bryant so he
stays with me for like four or five
slides and then he bumps me and I kind
of like fall off balance so I'm actually
gassed at this point I'm tired just
trying to get in the shape in the
preaching the game and he's just going
you know all out on the defensive
pressure and he's like he's way bigger
way stronger than me he's bumping me and
doing all that so after I fall I got no
option I'm like I'm just gonna shoot it
and live with it and I shot it from
probably 30 feet and I made it and then
I act like nothing happened so it's like
the biggest uh keep your cool kind of
moment in your life because you know
it's freaking Kobe you're trying to be
super chill about it but I just you know
drain one from 30 on it after he picked
me up and he gave me like the little ass
tap on the way back and I couldn't even
acknowledge that either I kind of just
like knocked him off and like act like I
was playing on defense
I went right back in at halftime I was
like I need that clip like bring me that
back I gotta say that on my phone and
the third time is what you're referring
to in terms of him kind of breaking down
the uh the Killer Instinct and I just
put it behind the smile like there's a
guys that like he was that had like the
scowl and the game face and like the
killer mentality he didn't have to say
anything you could see it like he's like
the joy that I play with and the smile
that I have you get deceived by just the
killer instinct that I had underneath
and the competitive spirit that I had
for somebody to validate you like that
um especially he's not giving out
compliments like that no no that was uh
that was truly special for sure
[Music]
all right whatever
I'm showing out today yeah for Real come
on it's a little bit better safe
what a run absolutely look at us right
hey
oh man I know I know
but it's all over
wings of death are behind us and you
know when I was watching the documentary
when I was watching the documentary and
reliving all these moments you know
they're so indelible to us sports fans
but I couldn't help but to think what it
must have been like for you to
experience them so with your brain on
fire your mouth Ablaze what I want to do
is Bounce a few moments from the dock
off of you some career highlights and
you just tell me the first couple of
things that come to mind when you think
about that night I'm good turning the
ball over 13 times in your college debut
against Eastern Michigan I can't wait
for everybody to see this because when I
saw the clip like you have a memory of
how bad it was in your head then you
imagine a hundred times worse when you
see it
so I literally like a like a baby
giraffe out there like I couldn't even
stay on my feet I could not and from me
to you right here I could not throw a
pass this way and the way that it's
edited it's all 13 turnovers literally
in a row
and just you see everybody's expression
my teammates like you know what the hell
is happening right now coach McCaleb you
can see his wheels are turned like we
just gave a scholarship to this kid like
what are we gonna step for four years
coming back down 17 to beat Georgetown
in the NCAA tournament unbelievable the
highlight of of the Run we won the next
game but that like getting out of that
first round and going to the second
round and beating the team like that
knowing
we're already overmatched in terms of
the seating but we're already down 17
second half unbelievable comeback for
sure breaking the all-time three record
with Ray Allen and Reggie Miller in
attendance
to do it in the garden
to do it with those two guys
I watched when when Ray broke Reggie's
record and Reggie was on the call so I
remember that it's kicking in right yeah
um I remember that moment it was you
know in Boston and they waited for a
timeout and he came over and hugged his
mom he went over and hugged Reggie so I
was kind of just imagining what that
would be like with me and it was it over
delivered so
after a special moment I got to give the
uh the game ball into my dad uh who was
sitting course out too a proud moment
and you know what I think you're only
going to add to the resume today taking
on the wings of death living to tell the
tales talk to me and now there's nothing
left to do but roll out the carpet for
you Steph Curry this camera this camera
this camera people know what you have
going on in your life hey make sure
check out the underrated documentary
Stephen Curry underrated coming out
Apple TV plus July 21st or whenever you
can get to your TVs and get these sauces
with it
ah
my eyes are freaking watering
these went away before you get to the
next Wing
here it stayed and then this one is just
that's a different level but you know
true to form you didn't stop you didn't
slow down your bites big dab at the end
you know as much as you're a challenge
you never took your foot off kids stuff
can't do it true to form can't do it
true to form oh my God
haha
thank you so much for watching today's
video I have a very exciting new product
alert last year hot ones brought the
heat to the freezer aisle with our first
ever hot ones boneless chicken bites
well now we are bringing even more heat
to the freezer aisle with our brand new
hot ones chicken strips made with our
first ever season blend two boldly
seasoned varieties you have the spicy
garlic featuring The Classic garlic
Fresno with mild heat and garlic blasted
goodness and Smoky habanero with the
tropical medium spice of our Los
Calientes Rojo we took the sauces that
you know and love and with a little
kitchen magic turned it into the perfect
season blend that go great on our new
hot ones chicken strips to find hot ones
chicken strips near you visit
hotoneschallenge.com that's
hotwingschallenge.com snack em dip them
make them the perfect party platter
[Music]